hello everyone welcome back to collider
for another exclusive
interview and it's another interview for
zoe's extraordinary playlist which you
all know i am mighty obsessed with but
i'm especially excited for this
interview because i covered it a little
bit last season but i never got to talk
to alex newell and now it's finally time
i'm so happy to have you here i can't
congratulate you enough
oh my god thanks for having me also
thanks for being a big fan of the show
huge huge fan uh admittedly uh
late to the game fan because i made
assumptions based on the first promo and
those were wrong i'm gonna keep
emphasizing that to anyone who assumes
that it's a certain thing because this
show has so much to offer
all right and rant let's talk about you
so i want our viewers to get to know you
a little bit
so kind of going back to the beginning
with this i'm curious what drew you at
first
to showing off your craft through a
reality tv competition and is there
anything about that experience that
you think maybe helped you hone your
craft that you might not have gotten
elsewhere
i mean you're going for the hard-hitting
questions of the glee project and i
thank you
um i was a wee
tiny little baby 18 year old who was a
fan of glee and
doing that show i i
oh my god it was like musical theater
television
boot camp i mean every day was a new
lesson
on how to perform in front of the camera
and how to sing
in a recording studio and how to act and
just like
we were working on godly hours from like
i mean they would turn the lights on in
our our bunk rooms
at like six in the morning and then
cameras were just fully
in there um that show prepared me for
everything so it's like
at three o'clock in the morning once
that now i'm just like what's up what
are we doing what's what's next
are we we're gonna do it again great
that's fun let's let's keep going
but no it really helped it honed in my
craft and
it really taught me all the lessons that
i would need that have
that i've used and give me all the tools
that i use to this day
i got another hard-hitting question for
this one for anybody else out there
because there's still
tons of reality competitions for anyone
out there who is going into one of those
in the entertainment field
what would you recommend them do to make
the most of the experience
you find a tribe and on the show
you can't think that it's a one-person
thing you have to
one trust to process to trust people
that are around you
and have fun i mean we were
genuinely very upset saying goodbye to
people at the end of the week
because we did like them we trusted them
we
were trying to do we had this great
common denominator
in common and so yeah it's you have to
be able to
be open and trust and not
be upset about looking like the [ __ ]
sometimes because that
happens i feel like a lot of that
advice i could back pocket and take to
like any environment out there and it'll
probably
so tiptoeing i guess into like glee
proper now
you jump into that show it's already you
know well into its run it's very popular
and this is like your first big
on-screen credits so
looking back is there anything about
that experience
the environment on set the people that
you are working with that now makes you
think i am so grateful i had that
experience on that set with those people
you know yes
it you're coming into such a well-oiled
machine
you're coming into some to these people
that have been doing this longer than
you have
and you have to be willing to listen and
be malleable to the experience because
you're coming into their house at the
end of the day and i was going into
their own
something that they've cultivated that
they've made the relationships that
they've had already
and you kind of have to
push your way in without pushing your
way in at the same time and i learned
so much from so many people on that show
um
and of just how to like
do little things that they weren't
teaching on the glee project like
finding my light
naira vera taught me how to find my
light she's like you just always have to
be in your life because like if you're
not in your life
you can't be seen and i was just like
what does that mean you're like find the
light
and you will be seen and i said oh okay
and it's stuff like that or just kind of
how to treat your body
throw throughout those long hours and
what you're putting in it
does come back out in a negative way
especially if you're working
16-hour days five days a week um
and yeah there's so many different life
lessons i'm super happy that i had on
that show specifically
so now i have to ask specifically
because i have a i have a coffee intake
problem and it serves me well
for a little while but then you crash
what is it that you turn to on a very
very long day on set that kind of keeps
that energy level up um
i i i'm the person that i'll have
little mini meltdowns if i'm really
tired
like just little ones and i'd be like oh
my god what is happening what is
happening
and i'll just have like a piece of candy
something sugary that not too
substantial a piece of candy to get you
through
because honey when you're exerting all
the energy
a lot of the time then also i'm a good
person to like
do a full bare minimum mark through
rehearsals um
if the camera's not on my face i'm
giving you the bare minimum
you do things that can serve your energy
throughout the day because
you learn um that if you keep giving
giving giving giving giving giving by
act not act i'm thinking i'm doing
broadway again but by act 2 you have
nothing
um by um take 35
you have nothing and you're burnt out
but a little piece of candy goes a long
way i also
am a coca-cola junkie sometimes so
a can of that and i'm good yeah i i got
a little of that in me as well
and you also paved the way perfectly to
my next question because i did want to
ask you about making your broadway debut
and specifically what did you learn from
that experience
even having had so much experience prior
what is it about the broadway day-to-day
that kind of
made you go i didn't know i had to adapt
in that way
i mean finding a daily routine i
was eating the same thing every day i
was drinking the same things every day i
was
doing the same things every single day
i'd wake up first thing in the morning
i'd get some coffee in me
i'd do some physical warm-ups to do some
vocal warm-ups
i'd run down get on the train get to the
theater
put my makeup on put the mic on run
around talk to everybody do the show
as soon as the curtain went out signed
and then went right to a bar
had a drink and then pressed repeat
every single
day i probably shouldn't have done the
bar thing every single night but you
know what i was young back then i was
dumb
but we've we've we've moved on we've
moved on but no you
find this like routine that you
continually
do all of the time and it's because
it it attributes not actually attributes
to
um the eight shows a week and doing the
same thing on stage eight shows a week
because
if you do something different in show
one
you create these bad habits in show two
and then
they carry to show three and then you
show it and you're just like why is
everything not where it needs to be what
is happening
but they have daily ritual routines
i feel like i give you a pass on the bar
thing though because you were right
smack in the heart of manhattan and
there are some good places to go
and like i'm a i'm a person person i
love being around people for as an only
child as an only child who grew up like
with a single parent who was working all
the time i was like there's nobody
around me right now i
feed off of people's energy and i just
love talking
and my cast and my crew and the people
that i worked with i adored still to
this day and like
going across the street to have a drink
and even then that was so routine
that i became friends with people that
worked at that bar and so it was like i
have to go say hi
that was trap i might have lived across
the street from that theater so i think
i probably know all the bars you were
going through
all right creeping closer to zoe now i
did want to ask about one other
pilot before i wanted to ask about
imaginary friend because i do think it's
valuable to talk about bumps in the road
along the way and how you overcame them
so
you get a lead role in a super cool show
like that and then it doesn't get picked
up after the pilot
how do you kind of not get super bummed
and keep your spirits up as you're
forging forward after something like
that
i've never seen it
i've i've never seen an imaginary friend
my mother seen it my neighbors have seen
it i have
so many people around me that have seen
it the person that was physically in it
me the imaginary friend titled imaginary
friend
never saw it i think that
really helped me kind of like
disassociate from it because
i filmed it so fast it was it was like a
two maybe three day shoot for me because
it was a 30 minute half hour
like sitcommie like i was in five scenes
with um uh megan um who was the lead i
forgot i don't even know
what her real name was on the show
that's how disassociated i am with that
show but i mean sometimes disassociating
from it does
kind of help you move on
at the end of the day because it was my
first
lead of a television show that wasn't
about me singing or being performative
was just baseline of me acting
and i could have gone down this giant
rabbit hole like i'm a terrible actor
it didn't get picked up it was me me me
me but it
i had nothing to do with it um i think
that
some things happen and some things don't
and if that show was a hit i wouldn't be
on zoe's now
just going back to something you just
said because i love you on zoey where i
get to see everything that you're
capable of but
is going with a uh just a
straightforward acting opportunity
something that you really want to get
next
i i don't want to say
yes but i don't want to say no maybe
i think to be honest last season
it was a lot of it was me just acting
and singing
every now and again um and which is a
180 from last season to this season
where i'm just like hey
hey let's go back to once last season
where was it singing as much
but um i i can't say no
because i do love singing and it is a
nice
time to show what you can do in
everything
can i put in a request to see you do a
little bit of everything
yes we're open to that but everything
else in the process
all right the very very beginning of zoe
because i already told everyone up top
what my first reaction to the show was
but what was yours
the very first um i don't know short
description one pager that crossed your
eyes what did you
think of the show compared to what it
turned out to be um
it's super strange um i remember getting
an
email from my agency manager being like
you have an audition for this new show
on a thursday and i said okay yay let's
see because
it was right around the time that um
we had just announced that once this
island was closing and i was just like
well on to the next
what's happening everybody and it was
pilot season
and i remember five minutes later
getting an email being like
jk it's cancelled and i was just like
all right nevermind and then 20 minutes
later i get a phone call being like
you're going straight to test can you go
to la tomorrow and i said
can you tell me what the project is and
they sent the materials again and the
breakdown of just reading who mo was
a carefree loving person that's always
high
that can sing and just knows
life and is expressive in life and then
30 year old bisexual black woman i said
i am
definitely not 30 but um we can keep
going with everything else we want to
but
or and i just love that this person
knows
music so well because music is my first
love and music
is something that i've always gravitated
to
and then as i was reading the script
and i got to this um little
uh i don't want to say monologue but but
this little speech that noah was giving
of how a good song can make you feel
things that
words can't express i'll always hold
that to me because
i've always believed that a good song
can make you feel things that words
can't express
i don't know what it is if it's the
melody if it's the lyric if it's just
you heard this song a long time ago in a
specific moment
and it's just it really expresses that
feeling and that emotion you're feeling
at that time
that sticks with you for your entire
life and i'm the first person to say
that music
always brings people together no matter
what if you like a song and somebody
else like a song but you have
differences
that song will bring you together
because if it's that one song there's so
many other songs just like that song
that you'll have in common and you
wouldn't know that
she had that in common with each other
i love the way you described that it
reminds me a lot of how i think about uh
just i guess tv and film in general too
a lot of times
those stories allow me to tap into
emotions and
you know certain forms of understanding
that i wouldn't be able to access
otherwise and that is why we need more
art in our lives all the time
all of the art all of the time i'm a
huge art junkie i love
just like sitting and i watch terrible
television
i mean i don't know why i didn't watch
imaginary friend but i'll watch anything
now i have to ask you what's the last
thing you binge watched i'm watching the
mick right now
i've heard good things about the mick it
is
mind-boggling how funny it is like
very funny i was just like this is
hilarious why did it get canceled i
don't ask questions like that but
because i know the answer is not what i
want to hear but
it was very funny i need to add that to
the list
as though i i don't have like a million
things to watch right now you're kind of
busy
i like it that way all right one thing i
love asking about in general
is being number one on the call sheet in
particular
what being number one on the call she
can mean for the tone on set
and just how everybody feels as far as
giving their best work so what does
jane do for you in that respect that you
really appreciate
oh jane
jane is just so giving in all of her
performances
she gives everything that she has
and i have to tell her like girl hold
back
i don't need all of that for my take
because you're killing yourself
um i you she's so giving as
a as an actor um looking into her eyes
every time that i'm either going through
something emotional or
very exciting or just how we spar with
each other she's just
she's still giving and accepting of a
lot as well
she does set that um that tone for me
at least i don't know what everybody
else could say but for me that's what
she sets a tone as
i love hearing that especially about
someone that i admire a lot and love
their work in general so it doesn't
surprise me she has that touch here
um i guess the bad transition here but
i'm curious about your experience
working with
different directors on each of the
episodes in particular the first episode
of season two
what is it like jumping back on set with
a director who wasn't part of season one
as a director and especially after
having had all that time
off is it still easy to kind of get back
into the swing of things
um yes and no
it's like you get the first script and
you're just like what is actually
happening or what
who is this character who is this person
i don't remember this person at all
and you still have those same questions
with a new director at the same time
where they're figuring it out and you've
had months off you've had a whole
pandemic
off to literally forget about who this
person
is and kind of go back to it um
working with a new director is kind of
fun in a way because
you have fresh eyes on all the
situations and new
options and choices that a plethora of
wealth of knowledge if you will of
someone that's just on the outside
looking in being like
hey i can guide you do you have
questions here's what i think here's
because i remember there was something
that i could not understand like i
literally just like
what is happening why am i doing this
why am i saying this
and john was just like it's this and i
was just like oh
all right and it just opened up this
everything clicked it opened up this
door and i was just like let's keep
going
i think it's nice to work with different
directors um
yeah i'm a fan of working with different
directors it gets stagnant working with
the same ones over and over again
but you know we in the middle of the
pandemic right now we only have two
directors
so it's not too stifling
that's a really interesting switch i
don't know how far you're
into shooting season two right now but
but how has that been sticking with just
these two directors
it's been nice because you know they go
on and off so one does the odds one does
the evens
and we're really just kind of
since they weren't here all last season
it's not like they know
everything so i think that part is nice
because that we still have these fresh
eyes on this text in this
world of everything and there's only so
much
you can do in some of these
texts and some of these musical numbers
and these emotions
and so they're very trusting with the
actors and letting us do
and express what we want but also
leading us in the right direction so
working with them
is kind of like oh oh right it's like
walking really
we're all just putting one foot in front
of the other random question have you
seen shopping mall
no can you please watch it so you could
talk to john about it i'm
a mile it's like it's an 80s horror
classic and i'm a little obsessed with
it
i'm i'm on it he gets killed off very
early but
it's a you know like it's a cheesy 80
slasher movie
we will watch anything john celeski's in
all right
i am gonna put up the spoiler warning
right now for the first two episodes of
zoe season two if you're not caught up
this next question is not for you so
there's the warning push pause go watch
the episodes then come right back and
the video picks up right here so you're
all set
so it's kind of ties back to something
you were just talking about i was
wondering
what your reaction was to learning about
mo's past
with his friend slash business partner
even having spent a whole season
in that role did it surprise you that he
was capable of doing that
yes it really did and that was one of
the things that
another one of those things i was like
what is this about and i had the
question of dawson was like
what is this about like this just pops
up out of nowhere
like what what what what what are we
doing and
he told me the story of how it's a
personal story to him and
i still was just like i don't get it it
seems so
so heavy for such like a light
topic like it's not like we're really
just
diving into this and going straight to
it and then
it took a director on anya to like
explain it
and say it's not really that it's like
the situation isn't what you're scared
of it's the
ruining a relationship with someone that
is new to you
because if you ruin that relationship
you ruin the relationship that you have
with zoe as well
because they're they're together they're
literally together
this episode and i think that
that weight of it all really clicked a
lot of things into perspective for me
that
this is someone that's fighting to keep
what they already have
because that relationship in the back's
already ruined and
they just like honestly i don't have to
do this i'm not going to find anything
i don't have to do any of this let's
just keep things as they are
because they're perfectly fine with how
they are right now
i also just appreciated the unique
approach to that kind of business
arrangement too
i feel like most perspective isn't one
we usually get to see it's usually the
obvious
of i don't want to enter into a business
agreement because i feel like i'm going
to get cheated out of something and
that's
like a very relatable other reaction you
could have to such a situation
so i appreciated that i mean once i
got there you definitely did i can
assure you that
um before i have to let you go here just
overall
i think you are giving viewers a lot
through this role
but what do you take from mo what is uh
something about his experience
that you hold on to every single day um
you know a fearlessness i think
mo is more fearless than i am i'm
extremely confident i am
very outlandish with my speech and
tongue and
expression but there is also a second
thought about a lot of things
and i do second think a lot of my
decisions my choices how i say things
when i say things
and mo doesn't and it's kind of if it
comes up it comes out and i
adore that about this character i
couldn't agree more that's just one of
many qualities that i love about mo and
alex you're awesome too i'm so happy we
finally got the chance to talk i'm
so happy for you with this show and
again
door wide open every opportunity you
want i want to go in your direction
thank you thank you so much for taking
the time of course big thanks to
everybody out there for watching this
interview zoe's extraordinary playlist
on nbc on tuesdays at 8 7 central
seriously you do not want to miss it
thank you guys for watching we'll see
you soon